so let's now get to the absolute
ignorant propaganda disinformation
nonsense from the NATO summit Donald
Trump as the world leaders were laughing
at him as they said during that hot mike
moment that we talked about already
Donald Trump took some questions in the
UK they talked about how Trump was late
because he answered questions for 40
minutes or something and his staff was
wondering what on earth is going on
those 40 minutes were riddled with
ridiculous ignorant malignant
disinformation and propaganda and it did
not go well being upstaged by French
president Emmanuel macron which I'll get
to a little bit later on in the show but
when the topic of climate change came up
during Trump's press conference
yesterday sort de-facto press conference
this is one of the four most
international and geopolitical issues of
our time Donald Trump's brain appeared
to malfunction or glitch and he seemed
unable to stop saying ridiculous things
we're gonna look at a couple of clips
this is again this is really tragic
because it's not just that Trump isn't
making sense on the topic of climate
change he's actively making the problem
worse he's not working with other world
leaders on the issue of climate he's
sending us back years in dealing with
the problem here's the first clip Trump
was asked whether he thinks about
climate change the concept of asking
Trump what he thinks about I find funny
I don't know why and Trump says he
believes very strongly in very very
crystal clear water and air this is what
it sounds like to have no idea what
you're talking about climate changes are
important to me and I've done many
environmental impacts sapiens over my
life
I believe in I believe very strongly and
very very crystal clear clean water and
clean air that's a big part of climate
change I also see what's happening with
our oceans where certain countries are
dumping unlimited loads of things in
there they float they tend to float
toward the United States I see that
happening and nobody's ever seen
anything like it
and it's gotten worse but no it's very
important to me also but I want clean
air and clean look with the number 1
number 2 he believes in crystal-clear
water very strongly I guess that's good
to know
but this is the way that a simpleton
understands an issue which is fine if
you're not President of the United
States
we don't need simplistic understandings
of the foremost issues of our time held
by the President of the United States
certain countries are dumping in the
oceans well what about us Donald because
we're doing that as well then a reporter
good for the reporter tries to drill
down a little more specifically into
this issue since Trump mentioned the
oceans the reporter asks about rising
sea levels and Trump with the generic
everything concerns me message shifts
over to talking about nuclear weapons
which wasn't even the point of the
question nuclear proliferation which i
think is a very important topic and it's
a topic that we're going to discuss
today you know the whole situation with
nuclear to me is very very important as
we've been discussing today at the
various meetings that we've had I think
that's something that has to be taken
care of and it has to be dealt with very
strongly that whole situation with
nuclear is important what had the ocean
oh yeah that to shore then Trump is
asked so you're here for a NATO summit
the whole point of NATO is it's a shared
defence agreement member countries come
to the defense of other member countries
if they are attacked militarily the US
would do that right mr. president
well Trump won't commit to that
which again is the whole point of NATO
Trump says if the country hasn't paid
what he thinks they should pay maybe we
won't defend them I guess is the point
here the link when did you put it in
paying for their defense that you commit
as president of the United States to
defend them if they were attacked well
you know I'm going to be discussing that
today and it's a very interesting
question isn't it and you know it also
depends on what your definition of
delinquents is for instance if you have
a country that's paying only 1% then you
have some that are paying less than 1%
and they shouldn't be you have something
to pay less than 1% and they're wealthy
dusters so Trump just going off and
talking about other things do other
countries oh back fees but not answering
the question would the United States
come to the defense of NATO member
nations as is the point of NATO's
existence but then hilariously and this
is so funny the Dow fell hundreds of
points yesterday and Trump was asked
about it while on screen the Dow was
down like more than 400 points and Trump
said that he doesn't watch the stock
markets which is so funny because on any
day that the stock market does well
Trump's tweeting about it Trump's
bragging about it Trump's using that to
justify that he has the best economy of
any president and you know the history
of the United States but yesterday was a
bad day for stocks and Trump says oh I
don't really pay attention to the stock
market but if the stock market goes up
again I don't watch the stock market i
watch jobs jobs are what i watch i watch
making the proper deal we've been taken
advantage of the United States by China
for so many years okay just one more and
we could go on all day with these Trump
was asked about the house intelligence
committees impeachment report here is
what Donald from said now I can't even
make heads or tails out of this one I
know at one point he seems to be talking
about that supposed Ukraine call
transcript which is of course not
a transcript it's like just a few
paragraphs and then I guess he starts
attacking Adam Schiff that's what they
saw we have a perfectly
beautiful 3/4 page transcription and
then in the other case the two page
transcription of the conversation but a
lot of people didn't read that how many
people pulled you a friend of mine go
about the top person in New York called
a great friend of mine very successful
gee I didn't like what was said I said
oh when did you see it did you read it
not angry that I heard Adam Schiff yeah
I said well that's not what was said and
I sent him a copy of what was said he
said this is like this is great this
isn't what he said this guy he said he
made up the conversation Eli if he
didn't do that in the halls of Congress
he'd be thrown into jail but he did it
in the halls of Congress and he's given
immunity this is a sick person he's a
liar
this is why world leaders are laughing
at him what on earth is this guy talking
about it makes me cringe it's really
embarrassing and we'll see today whether
Trump ruins NATO by the time this clip
is out we may know what impact Trump has
had on sort of the core NATO summit
meetings that are taking place today
Trump tweeting earlier about his meeting
with trumpian British prime minister
Boris Johnson of course saying it was
all absolutely great and fantastic I
wonder if Boris Johnson participating
and making fun of Trump yesterday in
that video came up my guess would be no
but we will see what actually comes from
the NATO summit discussions later today
leave a reply about this if you're
watching on YouTube what do you think
explains Trump's seemingly a cute brain
malfunction in these video clips or send
me a tweet at Deep hackman quick break
back after this with much more